[Musique]
J'étais lui hier en milieu de journée et
c'était vide et c'était un peu frénétique
maintenant aujourd'hui de voir cela se produire et il y
avait beaucoup de nourriture dans l'émission ouais j'ai
ce que je voulais
je  J'essaie de ne pas faire les
courses effrénées évidemment parce que je viens
plus tard dans la journée comme hier
qui est chaotique et ce matin a été
bien géré avec tous les mots
avec l'initiative pour laquelle ils sont maintenant
introduits pour les personnes âgées alors nous  disons
tous les matures entre 7h00
et 8h00 du matin tout le monde était
bien élevé là-dedans je n'ai que
des arrêts pour la journée comme vous pouvez le voir
[La musique]
est importante mais je ne pense pas qu'il soit le
meilleur  façon la meilleure façon je pense doit être
livrée calme parce que tu as l'air d'avoir 93
ans venir faire du shopping c'est mieux d'être
la livraison gratuite pour ce genre de personnes
[Musique] [
Musique]
toi
[Musique]